This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There are lessons to be learned in our failures. Touching a hot stove once will teach you to never touch a hot stove again, but when it comes to the failures of complex systems, it's sometimes hard to know what went wrong and when. This is where Tim Harford, also known as the undercover economist and his brand new show Coshnery Tales, comes in. It's a podcast that brings you stories of awful human error, tragic catastrophes,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们的失败中蕴含着深刻的教训。摸一次热炉子就会让你永远记住绝不再碰热炉子，但当涉及复杂系统的失败时，有时很难弄清究竟是什么出了错、又是在何时出错的。这就是蒂姆·哈福德登场的时候了，他也被称为“卧底经济学家”，他的全新节目叫《警世故事》（Cautionary Tales）。这是一个为你讲述可怕的人类失误、悲惨灾难的播客节目，
daring heists, and hilarious fiascoes. His stories will delight you, and if you're smart, they will scare the bejesus out of you. But they'll also make you wiser. The episode we're hearing today is about a fiasco that is often blamed on bad typography hence my specific interest in it, but the full explanation turned out to be much weirder and more surprising. Here's Tim Hartford with cautionary tales. You've heard this story before.
大胆的劫案以及荒诞的惨败。他的故事会让你大开眼界，如果你足够聪明，它们会吓得你魂飞魄散。但它们也会让你变得更加睿智。我们今天听到的这集是关于一场常被归咎于排版糟糕的惨败——这也是我对此特别感兴趣的原因，但最终的解释却要诡异和惊人得多。下面由蒂姆·哈福德为您带来《警世故事》。你以前听过这个故事。
You might even have watched it happening live. 33 million people did. There they stand, together on stage, fade on away and Warren Beatty, Bonnie and Clyde together again after 50 years. Even for a pair of veteran Hollywood stars, it must have been a nerve-wracking moment. Yet their tasks seemed simple. Open a red envelope, take out a card, and read out the title of the film that had won the Academy Award for Best Picture.
你甚至可能亲眼目睹了它的发生。有 3300 万人都看到了。他们就站在那里，一同站在舞台上，灯光渐暗，沃伦·比蒂和费·唐纳薇在时隔 50 年后再度同台。即便对于一对资深的好莱坞明星来说，这也是一个令人神经紧绷的时刻。然而他们的任务似乎很简单。打开一个红色的信封，拿出一张卡片，然后念出荣获奥斯卡最佳影片奖的电影片名。
Bati opens the envelope, so far so good. Then he looks at the card in his hand. He hesitates. Then he looks inside the envelope again as though checking to see if there was a cover note. He looks over at Dunnoway, then raises both eyebrows. She reaches over and touches his arm affectionately. He pauses again. He looks at the card again. He slips his hand inside the envelope one more time. The audience laughed
比蒂打开了信封，目前一切顺利。接着他看着手中的卡片。他犹豫了。然后他再次向信封里面看去，就像是在检查里面是不是还有一张附信。他看了看唐纳薇，然后扬起了双眉。唐纳薇伸手亲昵地碰了碰他的胳膊。他又停顿了一下。他再次看着卡片。他又一次把手伸进信封里。观众们笑了
at the moment of maximum tension that old rogue is playing with everyone's emotions. He continues, for a best picture, he stops again. Faye Dunnway thinks he's goofing around too. You're impossible she says, come on. He shows her the card. She doesn't hesitate for a moment. The audience erupts in applause and the producers of La La Lounge take to the stage to give their acceptance speeches. Meanwhile, off in the wings, an accountant named Brian Cen, knows that the biggest screw up in the history of the Academy Awards is in full flow. The 2016 winner of Best Picture isn't La La Land. It's moonlight.
在气氛最为紧张的那一刻，那个老顽童正在拿所有人的情绪开玩笑。他继续说道，关于最佳影片，他又停了下来。费·唐纳薇也以为他在耍宝。“你真拿他没办法，”她说，“快念吧。”他把卡片给她看。她没有一丝犹豫。台下爆发出一阵掌声，《爱乐之城》的制片人们走上台发表获奖感言。与此同时，在台幕后，一位名叫布莱恩·库利南的会计师知道，奥斯卡奖历史上最大的乌龙事件正在全面上演。2016 年的最佳影片得主根本不是《爱乐之城》。而是《月光男孩》。
So, yes, you've heard this story. But have you understood what it really means? You're listening to another cautionary tale. There's a simple way to tell the story of this fiasco, as Warren Beatty walked on stage, Brian Cullenen's job was to hand him the envelope for best picture. Instead, Cullenen handed over the envelope for best actress. A few moments earlier, that award had been won by Emma Stone for her performance in La La Land. And so, when Beaty opened the envelope, he saw Emma Stone, La La Land. Jimmy Kimmel, the host of the Oscars that evening, jokingly blamed it all on Bati.
所以，没错，你听说过这个故事。但你真正理解它的含义了吗？你正在收听的是另一个《警世故事》。有一个简单的方法来讲述这场惨败的故事：当沃伦·比蒂走上舞台时，布莱恩·库利南的工作就是把最佳影片的信封交给他。然而，库利南交出的却是最佳女主角的信封。就在几分钟前，艾玛·斯通凭借在《爱乐之城》中的精彩表演刚刚赢得了该奖项。因此，当比蒂打开信封时，他看到的是：艾玛·斯通，《爱乐之城》。当晚奥斯卡颁奖典礼的主持人吉米·坎摩尔开玩笑地将这一切归咎于比蒂。
Warren, what did you do? I wanted to tell you what happened. But it really wasn't Bati's fault. He didn't understand what he was looking at, and rather than say the wrong thing, he hesitated. Then he turned to fade underway. She was the person who actually uttered the title of the wrong film, but it wasn't her fault either. Imagine her situation. She's on stage in front of the most star-studded audience imaginable, plus tens of millions watching live on television. Beaty seems to be messing
“沃伦，你到底做了什么？”我想告诉大家当时发生了什么。但这真的不是比蒂的错。他看不懂自己面对的是什么，与其说错话，不如选择犹豫。然后他转向了费·唐纳薇。正是她真正说出了那部错误电影的片名，但这也不是她的错。想象一下她的处境。她站在舞台上，面对着你能想象到的最大牌的明星观众，以及通过电视直播观看节目的几千万观众。比蒂似乎在胡闹，而她不知道为什么。她在卡片上看到的第一行字就是《爱乐之城》，所以她脱口而出的就是这个。有些人责怪比蒂，有些人责怪唐纳薇，大多数人责怪布莱恩·库利南——那个递错了信封的会计师。但我认为所有这些人全怪错了。将近十年前，在这场惨败发生的数年前，我采访了全球最重要的事故成因思想家之一。他是一位名叫查尔斯·佩罗的社会学家，他告诉我的一番话深深印在了我的脑海里：我们总是责怪操作员。他说，这总是一起“飞行员失误”。查尔斯·佩罗是一位充满智慧的老人。
around, and she doesn't know why. The first thing she sees on the card is La La Land, and straight away that's what she says. Some people blame Beaty, some people blame Dunnoay, most people blame Brian Cullenen, the accountant who handed over the wrong envelope. But all of those people I think are making a mistake. Almost a decade ago, years before this fiasco, I interviewed one of the world's most important thinkers on how accidents happen. He's a sociologist named Charles Perot, and he told me something that stuck in my mind, that we always blame the operator. It's always, he says, a case of pilot error. Charles Perot is a wise old man.
他比奥斯卡奖本身的年龄还要大。1929 年奥斯卡首次颁奖时，他已经四岁了。佩罗说得绝对没错。我们不可避免地会寻找替罪羊，而这种倾向把我们引上了歧途。我们的本能是将责任归咎于会计师布莱恩·库利南，因为他确实把错误的信封给了比蒂。他当时分心了。他发了一条推特，配了一张艾玛·斯通手拿奥斯卡小金人的照片。
He's older than the Academy Awards themselves. He was four back in 1929 when they were first presented. And Perot is absolutely right. We inevitably look for someone to blame, and that inclination leads us astray. Our instinct is to blame the accountant, Brian Colullinan, he did give Beaty the wrong envelope. He was distracted. He'd tweeted a photograph of Emma Stone holding her Oscar statuette.
就在他本该专注于把正确的信封交给比蒂的时候，他却在玩手机，享受着在人生高光时刻与全球最美的人之一近距离接触的喜悦。我们都可以从中吸取教训。放下手机，当你本该和家人共进晚餐时放下手机，当你本该开车时放下手机，当你本该把装有最佳影片卡片的信封交给沃伦·比蒂时，放下手机。但简单归咎于库利南之所以是一个错误，是因为库利南只是
At a time he should have been focusing on giving Beaty the right envelope, he was on his phone, enjoying being close to one of the world's most beautiful people at her moment of triumph. We can all learn a lesson from that. Get off your phone, get off your phone when you're supposed to be having dinner with your family, get off your phone when you're supposed to be driving, and get off your phone when you're supposed to be giving the envelope containing the best picture card to Warren Beatty. But the reason that it's a mistake to simply blame Colonyn is because Colonyn was just
在表现人性。人类总是会分心。人类总是会犯错。如果我们的系统无法应对这些错误，那么要求人们表现得更好就是无望的。我们需要更好的系统。当《爱乐之城》短暂地赢得奥斯卡最佳影片时，一些富有且成功的人士遭受了一些尴尬和心碎，但没有人死亡。然而这场惨败给我们的教训绝非微不足道。在不同情况下发生同样的错误可能会造成灾难性的后果。
being human. Humans are always getting distracted. Humans are always making mistakes. If our systems can't cope with those mistakes, then it's hopeless to demand better humans. We need better systems. When La La land, fleetingly one moonlight oscar, some rich and successful people suffered some embarrassment and some heartache, but nobody died. Yet the lessen of the fiasco is far from trivial. The same kind of mistake in different situations can be catastrophic.
此类错误可能导致核事故和金融崩溃，而我说“可能导致”的意思是，已经导致了——此类灾难已经发生过了。因此，让我们试着去理解在奥斯卡那个诡异的夜晚究竟发生了什么。也许我们可以利用这种洞察力来防止更严重的灾难。我们来谈谈第一个问题：糟糕的排版。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但事实确实如此，比蒂从信封里拿出的卡片上写着九个字，其中最大的字是“奥斯卡”（Oscars）。真的吗？这真的是最核心的信息吗？难道我们在担心，如果没有它，沃伦·比蒂会以为自己身处爱荷华州集市，在颁发最佳母猪奖章吗？“爱乐之城”（La La Land）和“艾玛·斯通”（Emma Stone）这两个词的字重是相等的，尽管获奖者是艾玛·斯通，其余的都只是细节。与此同时，最重要的字眼“最佳女主角”（Best Actress）却被挤在卡片的最下方，而且字号极小。如果“最佳女主角”字样醒目，沃伦·比蒂就不会感到困惑，他就会知道自己手里拿错了卡片。如果艾玛·斯通的字号比《爱乐之城》更大，费·唐纳薇也就不会脱口而出错误电影的名字了。对比蒂和唐纳薇来说，走下舞台去拿正确的信封可能会有些尴尬，但跟不走下舞台去拿正确信封相比，那可就一点也不尴尬了。
Such mistakes can lead to nuclear accidents and financial meltdowns, and when I say, can lead, I mean, have led such disasters have already occurred. So, let's try to understand what really happened that strange night at the Oscars. Perhaps we can use that insight to prevent far more serious calamities. Let's talk about problem number one, bad typography. I know it sounds strange, but it's true, the card that Bati took out of the envelope had nine words on it, and the largest word is, oscars. Really? Is that really the most important piece of information? Are we worried that without it, Warren Beaty's going to think he's at the Iowa State Fair handing out a medallion for the best hog. The words La La Land and Emma Stone are printed with equal
所以奥斯卡主办方本该雇个设计师，但他们并不是唯一这样的人。想象一下，你是核电站的夜班主管。现在是凌晨四点，你还不知道的是，带走反应堆堆芯热量的涡轮系统刚刚关闭了。你将不得不做出一些快速决定，前提是你能弄清楚哪里出了问题。为什么？那是什么？让我看看。我想那是警报声！我们能把它关掉吗？
weight, even though the winner is Emma Stone, the rest is detail. Meanwhile, the important words best actress are tucked away at the bottom of the card, and they're tiny. If best actress had been prominent, Warren Beatty wouldn't have been confused he would have known that he had the wrong card in his hand. And if Emma Stone had been in larger type than La La Land, Faye Dunnoay wouldn't have blurted out the name of the wrong film. It would have been awkward for Beatty and Dunnoay to walk off stage to get the right envelope, but not nearly as awkward as not walking off stage to get the right envelope.
我觉得……不行。你能吗？在事故发生的前几分钟，有一百多个警报器同时响起，而且没有任何系统可以屏蔽那些不重要的信号，以便操作人员集中精力处理重大警报。信息没有以清晰且足够易懂的形式呈现出来。这段话摘自对 1979 年三里岛核事故（当时可以说是全球最严重的核事故）官方调查的概述。
So the Academy should have hired a designer, but they're not the only ones. Imagine that you're the night shift supervisor at a nuclear power plant. It's 4 o'clock in the morning, and you don't know it yet, but the turbine system that draws away the heat from the reactor core has just shut down. You're going to have to make some quick decisions, assuming you can figure out what's going wrong. And why? What's that? Let's see. I think it's a key noise! Can we shut it down?
它摧毁了反应堆，差一点在东海岸造成放射性物质的大规模泄漏，并彻底粉碎了美国核工业的声誉。调查如此迅速地聚焦于设计问题，这令人印象深刻。但对于任何研究事故如何发生的人来说，这一点也不令人意外。该电厂的控制室设计得如此糟糕，以至于错误在所难免。加州大学圣迭戈分校设计实验室主任唐·诺曼，
I think...no. Can you? During the first few minutes of the accident, more than a 100 alarms went off, and there was no system for suppressing the unimportant signals so that operators could concentrate on the significant alarms. Information was not presented in a clear and sufficiently understandable form. That's from the overview of the official inquiry into what was then arguably the world's most serious nuclear accident at 3 Mile Island in 1979.
受邀协助分析三里岛核事故的问题。出问题的是设计，而不是操作员。控制面板令人匪夷所思。上面显示了将近 750 个灯，有些在相关开关的旁边、上方或下方，有时甚至与相关开关毫无关系。红灯表示阀门打开或设备运行，绿灯表示阀门关闭或设备停运，但由于有些灯通常是红色的，而另一些通常是绿所以，没错，操作人员在三里岛犯了错误，但如果设计得更好，他们可能就不会犯错了。沃伦·比蒂和费·唐纳薇对此会感同身受。
It destroyed the reactor, came close to a serious release of radioactive material on the eastern seaboard, and shattered the reputation of the American nuclear industry. It's striking how quickly the inquiry focused in on the question of design. But to anyone who studies how accidents happen, it's not surprising at all. The plan's control rooms were so poorly designed that error was inevitable. Don Norman, the director of the design lab at UC San Diego,
但奥斯卡当晚还出了别的问题，更深层、更令人惊奇的问题。这是一种奇怪的效应，最早是由一位因仰望星空而闻名、而不是因探究事物为何出错而闻名的伟大人物所观察到的。伽利略·伽利莱以其天文学成就而闻名，而且由于他的著作曾被列入教会的《禁书目录》（Index Librorum Prohibitorum）。但这位伟人的最后一部著作
was asked to help analyze the problems at Three Mile Island. Design was at fault, not the operators. The control panels were baffling. They displayed almost 750 lights, some next to the relevant switches, or above them, or below them, sometimes nowhere near the relevant switch at all. Red lights indicated open valves or active equipment. Green indicated closed valves or inactive equipment, but since some of the lights were typically red and others were normally green,
开篇却是一个不那么具有挑衅性的主题：如何在建筑工地上正确存放石柱。请听我细讲，这本出版于 1638 年的书将解释奥斯卡乌龙事件以及更多内容。我必须叙述一个值得你注意的情况，正如所有意料之外发生的事件一样。尤其是当一项预防措施最终成为灾难的起因时。一项预防措施最终成为了灾难的起因，这非常有趣，伽利略。请继续说。
the overall effect was dizzying. So, yes, the operators made mistakes at 3 mile island, but with better design, they might not have. Warren Beatty and Faye Dunnoay would sympathise. But something else went wrong that night at the Oscars, something deeper and more surprising. It's a strange effect and it was first observed by a man less famous for looking at why things go wrong, and more famous for looking at the stars. Galileo Galilei is known for his astronomy, and because his work was consigned to the Church's indexly brawrum-prohibitorum, the list of forbidden books. But the Great Man's final work
一根大型大理石柱被放置好，使其两端分别支撑在一根横梁上。我能在脑海中想象出那个画面：在水平存放准备使用时支撑住柱子。如果你把它放在地上，它可能会被弄脏，而当你试图把绳子塞到它下面把它拉直时，你可能会把它弄断。所以没错，平放它，但用一端和另一端的支架将其撑起。但如果柱子无法承受自身的重量而直接从中间折断了呢？伽利略考虑到了这一点。
opens with a less provocative topic, the correct method of storing a stone column on a building site. There with me, this book from 1638 is going to explain the Oscar Fiasco and much more. I must relate to circumstance which is worthy of your attention, as indeed are all events which happen contrary to expectation. Especially when a precautionary measure turns out to be a cause of disaster. A precautionary measure turns out to be a cause of disaster, that's very interesting Galileo. Please go on.
不久之后，一位机械师想到，为了双保险确保它不在中间断裂，在正中间加设第三个支架是明智的。大家觉得这是一个绝妙的主意。是的，如果两个支架很好，那么三个支架肯定更好。事实却恰恰相反。因为没过几个月，人们就发现柱子在紧挨着新增的中间支架的正上方裂开并折断了。
A large marble column was laid out so that its two ends rested each upon a piece of beam. I can picture that in my mind, support the column while it's being stored horizontally, ready for use. If you lay it on the ground, it may get stained, and you'll probably break it when you try to get ropes underneath it to pull it upright. So yes, store it flat, but propped up by a support at one end and a support at the other. But what if the column can't support its own weight like that and simply snaps in half? Galileo has thought of that.
这是怎么发生的？其中一个端部支架在过了很长时间后开始腐烂并下沉，但中间的支架依然坚硬结实，从而导致柱子的一半悬空，没有任何支撑。中央支架并没有让柱子更安全。它像跷跷板的中心支点一样压入柱子，将其拦腰折断。伽利略的故事其实不是关于存放柱子的，我的故事也不是。它是关于我所称的“伽利略定律”的。我们为确保自身安全而采取的步骤，有时反而会把我们带入危险之中。伽利略所描述的问题，安全工程师们都非常清楚。在学术期刊《过程安全进展》（Process Safety Progress）上有一篇文章，
A little later, it occurred to a mechanic that, in order to be doubly sure of its not breaking in the middle, it would be wise to lay a third support midway. This seemed to all an excellent idea. Yes, if two supports are good, surely three supports are better. It was quite the opposite. For not many months passed before the column was found cracked and broken, exactly above the new meter support.
标题是《好心不得好报：防护系统导致事故及潜在事故的案例研究》。这些案例研究非常精彩。有一个化工厂，两个泄压系统以某种方式相互干扰，导致两者都无法工作。有一个旨在销毁污染物的火炬，结果却导致了有毒气体的释放。还有一个会引发爆炸的抑爆装置。这种事情发生的频率比你想象的要高。一个例子是费米 1 号（Fermi-1）发生的早期核事故之一，这是密歇根州的一个实验反应堆。
How did that happen? One of the end supports had, after a long while, become decayed and sunken, but the middle one remained hard and strong, thus causing one half of the column to project in the air without any support. The central support didn't make the column safer. It pressed into it like the central pivot of a seasaw snapping it in half. Galileo's tale isn't really about storing columns, and neither is mine. It's about what I'm going to call Galileo's principle. The steps we take to make ourselves safe sometimes lead us into danger. The problem Galileo described is well known to safety engineers. There's an article in the Fine Scholarly Journal process safety progress.
现在几乎没人记得它了，除了吉尔·斯科特-埃伦（Gil Scott-Heron）的歌曲《这一次我们差点失去了底特律》。费米 1 号的操作员失去了对核反应的控制，原因令他们百思不得其解。部分反应堆燃料熔化了，当时千钧一发。最终他们控制住了反应堆，将其全部关闭，并等待安全拆解的时机。差不多过了一年，反应堆冷却到足以找出罪魁祸首的程度。一块压扁的啤酒罐大小的金属片阻塞了反应堆堆芯中冷却剂的循环。
Titled, no good deed goes unpunished. Case studies of incidents and potential incidents caused by protective systems. These case studies are magnificent. There's a chemical plant where two pressure relief systems interact in a way that means neither of them work. There's a flare designed to destroy pollutants, which ends up causing the release of toxic gases. There's an explosion suppression device that causes an explosion. This kind of thing happens more than you might think. An example is one of the earliest nuclear accidents at Fermi-1, an experimental reactor in Michigan.
这是一个在核管会的明确要求下，为了安全起见而在最后一刻安装的过滤器。它松动了，并导致了整个问题的发生。“伽利略定律”再次应验。为什么安全系统有时会产生反效果？睿智的老社会学家查尔斯·佩罗最著名的书名叫《正常事故》（Normal Accidents）。它探讨了某些类型的系统为何容易发生灾难性故障。事实上，这些系统如此脆弱，以至于我们应该将这些系统中的事故视为不可避免的。脆弱的系统有两个特征。
It's barely remembered now, except in Gil Scott Heron's song, we almost lost Detroit this time. The operators at Fermi-1 lost control of the nuclear reaction, for reasons that were baffling to them. Some of the reactor fuel melted, it was all touch and go. Eventually they got the reactor under control, shut it all down, and waited until it was safe to take it all apart. It was almost a year before the reactor had cooled enough to identify the culprit. A piece of metal, the size of a crushed beer can had blocked the circulation of the coolant in the reactor core.
第一个特征是佩罗所称的“紧密耦合”。在一个紧密耦合的系统中，一环扣一环，事件接连发生。这就像多米诺骨牌倒塌，实际上它正是紧密耦合系统的绝佳例子。一旦开始，就很难按下暂停键。第二个特征是复杂性。复杂系统包含以意想不到的方式相互作用的要素。热带雨林是一个复杂系统，哈佛大学也是。但哈佛大学通常不是紧密耦合的。
It was a filter that had been installed at the last moment for safety reasons at the express request of the Nuclear Regulatory Commission. It had come loose and caused the entire problem. Galileo's principle strikes again. Why do safety systems sometimes backfire? The wise old sociologist Charles Perot's most famous book is called Normal Accidents. It's about how certain kinds of system are vulnerable to catastrophic failure. So vulnerable, in fact, that we should view accidents in those systems as inevitable. The vulnerable systems have two features.
如果出现了问题，也还有时间去寻找解决方案。既复杂又紧密耦合的系统是危险的。复杂性意味着偶尔会出现意外。紧密耦合意味着将没有时间去应对这些意外。紧密耦合意味着将没有时间去应对这些意外。查尔斯·佩罗的理论解释了“伽利略定律”。每当你增加一个旨在防止某个问题的特性时，你就增加了一份复杂性。柱子的中间支架增加了复杂性。损坏费米 1 号反应堆的安全过滤器也是如此。
The first is that they're what perot calls tightly coupled. In a tightly coupled system, one thing leads to another and another and another. It's like domino toppling, which is actually a great example of a tightly coupled system. Once you start, it's hard domino toppling, which is actually a great example of a tightly coupled system. Once you start, it's hard to hit the pause button. A second feature is complexity. A complex system has elements that interact in unexpected ways. A rain forest is a complex system, so is Harvard University. But Harvard University usually isn't tightly coupled.
安全系统并不总是能保证我们的安全。损坏费米 1 号反应堆的安全过滤器也是如此。安全系统并不总是能保证我们的安全。更多蒂姆·哈福德的《警世故事》将在 99% Invisible 广告之后继续播出。这里是我们针对奥斯卡那个离奇夜晚应该提出的问题：为什么分心记账员布莱恩·库利南竟然有可能把错误的信封交给沃伦·比蒂？就在几分钟前，最佳女主角的信封——那个装有写着“艾玛·斯通，《爱乐之城》”卡片的信封——曾掌握在莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥手中，当时他正站在舞台上宣布她获奖。
If there's a problem, there's also time to find a solution. A system that's both complex and tightly coupled is dangerous. The complexity means there will occasionally be surprises. The tight coupling means that there will be no time to deal with the surprises. The tight coupling means that there will be no time to deal with the surprises. Charles Perot's theory explains Galileo's principle. Every time you add a feature that's designed to prevent a problem, you're adding complexity. The middle support for the column added complexity. So did the safety filter that damaged the Fermi-1 reactor.
那个信封怎么会落入沃伦·比蒂的手中？答案是……它并没有。有两个信封。每个类别的每个信封，在台幕后都有一个备份版本在等待着。这些重复的信封作为一种安全措施放在那里。而正是这种安全措施，让这场乌龙事件成为了可能。“伽利略定律”狠狠地应验了。查尔斯·佩罗的论点是，当系统既复杂又紧密耦合时，我们应该
Safety systems don't always make us safe. So did the safety filter that damaged the Fermi-1 reactor. Safety systems don't always make us safe. More of Tim Harvard's cautionary tales are 99% invisible after this. Here's the question we should be asking about that bizarre evening at the Oscars. How was it even possible for the distracted accountant Brian Cullenon to give Warren Beatty the wrong envelope? A few minutes earlier, the envelope for best actress, the envelope containing the card that read Emma Stone La La Land, that envelope had been in the hands of Leonardo DiCaprio, as he stood on stage announcing her win.
预料到灾难性事故的发生。奥斯卡颁奖典礼符合这个描述吗？它绝对是紧密耦合的，你无法轻易在数百万观众面前打断一场电视直播去寻求建议。演出必须继续。然而，典礼本身并不需要那么复杂。把信封交给沃伦·比蒂并不需要多么复杂。但是，如果你非要尝试，你就能把它搞得复杂无比。
How could that envelope have made its way into the hands of Warren Beatty? The answer...it didn't. There were two envelopes. Every envelope, for every category, had a duplicate version waiting in the wings. These duplicate envelopes were there, as a safety measure. And that safety measure is what made the fiasco possible. Galileo's principle had bitten hard. Charles Perot's argument is that when systems are both complex and tightly coupled, we should
布莱恩·库利南当晚的共犯是玛莎·鲁伊兹（Martha Ruiz）。和库利南一样，她也是一位资深会计师。两人携带的手提箱一模一样，里面装着完全相同的信封。在颁奖典礼当天，我们会拿到选票，然后我和布莱恩会走两条不同的路线去剧院。他走一条路，我走另一条路。这就是玛莎·鲁伊兹在奥斯卡之夜前夕向记者们耐心解释的方式。她和库利南一直骄傲地接受关于这个天衣无缝系统的采访。
expect catastrophic accidents. Does the Academy Award ceremony fit that description? It's certainly tightly coupled, you can't easily interrupt a live TV spectacular in front of millions of people to ask for advice. The show must go on. Yet, the ceremony doesn't have to be complex. Giving an envelope to Warren Beatty doesn't have to be complex. But you can make it complex, if you try.
我们这样做是为了确保，万一其中一人出了什么情况，另一个人能按时带着全套信封准时到达并交付所需物品。直到我们到达剧院并将信封在他们走上舞台前几秒钟交给出场嘉宾之前，我们一直都有安全措施。我们会在两个不同的地点，布莱恩在舞台右侧，我会在舞台左侧。这一切听起来都很合理，在很多方面也确实很合理。但它也很复杂。双信封系统意味着，每当舞台上打开一个信封时，台幕后的备份信封就必须被搁置一旁。
Brian Cullenen's partner in crime that evening was Martha Ruiz. Like Cullenen, she was a senior accountant. The pair of them carried identical briefcases with an identical set of envelopes. On the day of the show, we'll get the ballots and Brian and I will go to the theatre on two separate roads. He'll go one route and I'll go another route. That's how Martha Ruiz helpedfully explain things to journalists just before Oscar night. Both she and Colonnon have been proudly giving interviews about the foolproof system.
舞台左侧的玛莎·鲁伊兹将最佳女主角的信封交给了莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，这就留下了舞台右侧的布莱恩·库利南去处理销毁备份信封的工作——而这正是他未能完成的工作。如果没有那套双重信封，沃伦·比蒂绝不可能拿到错误的信封。因此，糟糕的设计导致了奥斯卡乌龙事件。它也导致了三里岛核事故。而复杂的安全系统则是奥斯卡乌龙事件的根源。它也是费米 1 号事故的根源。
We do that to ensure that in case anything happens to one, the other will be there on time and delivering what's needed with the full set. We do have security measures up until we're at the theater and delivering that envelope to the presenter just seconds before they walk on stage. We'll be in two different locations, Brian will be on stage right and I'll be on stage left. It all sounds sensible and in many ways it is sensible. It's also complicated. The system of twin envelopes meant that every time an envelope was opened on stage, its duplicates in the wings had to be set aside.
但不仅限于奥斯卡和核电。我还答应过你一场金融灾难。在这场灾难中，安全系统和糟糕的排版都难辞其咎，你甚至可能会以一种截然不同的眼光看待这场银行危机。2008 年 9 月，在金融危机的高峰期，一位名叫罗伯特·威兰stad（Robert Willumstad）的高管要求与蒂姆·盖特纳（Tim Geithner）会面。盖特纳后来成为了财政部长。当时他是纽约联邦储备银行的行长。这意味着他负责
Martha Ruiz, stage left, handed the envelope for best actress to Leonardo DiCaprio, leaving Brian Cullinan, stage right, with a job of discarding the duplicate, the job he failed to do. If there hadn't been that set of twin envelopes, Warren Beatty could never have been given the wrong one. So, bad design helped cause the Oscar Fiasco. It also helped cause the accident at Three Mile Island. And a complicated safety system was at the root of the Oscar fast. It was also at the root of the Fermi-1 accident.
监管华尔街的银行，包括正处于崩溃边缘的雷曼兄弟。罗伯特·威兰stad是一家名为 AIG 的保险公司的老板，既然 AIG 不是一家银行，为什么威兰stad成了盖特纳的麻烦，这就很不明显了。记者安德鲁·罗斯·索尔金（Andrew Ross Sorkin）在他的著作《大而不倒》（Too Big To Fail）中详细记录了这场注定失败的会面的私密细节。“真的很抱歉，威兰stad先生。盖特纳先生还要几分钟。”“没关系。我有时间。”“对不起，我知道您已经等很久了。盖特纳先生正在和
But it's not just Oscars and Nuclear Power. I promised you a financial catastrophe too. And in this one, both safety systems and bad typography at a blame, you might even start to see the banking crisis in a very different light. In September 2008, at the height of the financial crisis, an insurance executive named Robert Willemstad, requested a meeting with Tim Geithner. Geithner would later be the Treasury Secretary. At the time, he was the President of the New York Federal Reserve. That meant he was responsible
雷曼兄弟的老板通电话。他已经深陷雷曼的泥潭了。”蒂姆·盖特纳也精疲力竭。他刚坐了瑞士银行会议后的红眼航班赶回来。他一定感到彻底分身乏术了。谁不会呢？“呃，鲍勃，是吧？抱歉让你久等了，请进。”威兰stad终于得到了面谈的机会。他极其迫切地希望能向美联储借款，这通常不是 AIG 被允许做的事情，但他也不想吓到盖特纳。他必须走钢丝，暗示 AIG 需要一些帮助，但实际上并没有破产。“这是一个紧急或危机情况吗，鲍勃？”“嗯，你知道的，我只能说这对 AIG 来说会非常有益，盖特纳先生。也许我可以把这个留给你。”威兰stad递给盖特纳一份简报。藏在其中的是一颗
for supervising Wall Street's banks, including Lehman-Rubbers, which was on the brink of collapse. Robert Willemstad was the boss of an insurance company called AIG and since AIG wasn't a bank, it was far from obvious why Willemstad was Geithner's problem. In his book Too Big To Fail, the journalist Andrew Ross-Sorkin reports the intimate details of this ill-fated meeting. I'm really sorry, Mr. Will instead. Mr. Gatner is going to be a few minutes. No problem. I have time. I'm sorry, I know you've been waiting a long time. Mr. Gatner is on the phone to the
正在倒计时的大定时炸弹。华尔街最大的几家公司正指望 AIG 来支付金融动荡的保险赔偿。承保的总金额高达荒谬的 2.7 万亿美元。如果所有理赔都找上门来，AIG 根本无力支付，而且情况开始看起来
boss of Lehman Brothers. He's up to his eyeballs and Lehman. Tim Geithner was also exhausted. He'd been on an overnight flight from a banking conference in Switzerland. He must have felt completely overwhelmed. Who wouldn't have? Uh, Bob, is it? Sorry to keep you waiting, come in. Willemstadt got his moment. He badly needed to be able to borrow from the Fed, not normally something AIG would be allowed to do, but he also didn't want to panic Geithner. He needed to walk a tight rope to suggest that AIG could use some help, but wasn't actually bankrupt. Is this a critical or emergency situation, Bob? Well, you know, let me just say that it would be
它们似乎真的会这么做。但这意味着华尔街的大银行将无法获得他们所依赖的保险赔付。AIG 对金融系统的威胁不仅比雷曼兄弟更大，而且更令人惊意外。如果说 AIG 是一个安全网，那它也是一个无法接住任何人的安全网。但要意识到这一点，蒂姆·盖特纳实际上必须阅读并消化备忘录中的信息。而他很忙。真的很忙。
very beneficial to AIG, Mr. Geigner. Perhaps I can leave this with you. Willemstadt handed Geigner a briefing note. Berid, deep within it, was a fast ticking time bomb. The largest firms on Wall Street were relying on AIG to pay out on insurance against financial trouble. The total sum insured was a truly ludicrous $2,700 billion. AIG couldn't possibly pay if all the claims came in, and it was starting to look as though
所以他干脆把它归档，转头去处理雷曼兄弟的问题。几天后，AIG 崩溃了。这与奥斯卡之夜的相似之处简直不可思议。一方面，并不是傻瓜的盖特纳根本不知道该如何解读他所看到的内容。这是意料之外的，关键信息被埋在了小字里。费·唐纳薇和沃伦·比蒂对此心知肚明。还有就是伽利略定律。安全系统并不总是能保证我们的安全。那些保险
they might. But that meant that the big Wall Street banks wouldn't get the insurance payments they were relying on. AIG was both a bigger threat to the financial system than Lehman Brothers and a far more surprising one. If AIG was a safety net, it was one that wasn't going to break anyone's fall. But to realise that, Tim Geithner would actually have to read and absorb the information in the note. And he was busy. Really busy.
合同本意是为了对冲风险，而不是创造风险，对吧？但现在我们知道，安全系统也引入了让事情出差错的新途径。即将摧毁 AIG 的保险合同被称为信用违约互换（CDS）。在监管机构的祝福下，它们作为对冲风险的一种方式变得流行起来。它们当时看起来是个明智的主意。正如柱子的第三个支架听起来是个明智的主意一样，费米反应堆的金属过滤器和成套的备用奖杯信封也是如此。但它们适得其反。华尔街的银行指望这些信用违约互换在遇到麻烦时能保它们安全。
So instead he filed it away and turned back to the Lehman Brothers problem. AIG would melt down a few days later. The parallels with Oscar Knight are uncanny. For one thing, Geithner, who's no fool, had no idea how to interpret what he was looking at. It was unexpected and the key information was buried in the small print. Fade on away and Warren Beatty know the feeling. Then there's Galileo's principle. Safety systems don't always make us safe. Those insurance
当人们清楚地看到像 AIG 这样的保险公司根本无力赔付时，所有的银行都在同一时间、出于完全相同的原因，争先恐后地抛售他们的高风险投资。在威兰stad与盖特纳会面几天后，官员和银行家们整个周末都在加班处理雷曼兄弟的问题。直到周日晚上，其中一位银行家才接到财政部官员的请求，问她能否放下手头的一切，转而去拯救 AIG。这个出人意料的电话得到了一个毫不意外地不适合家人收听的回答：“等等，等等。你在周日晚上打电话给我，说我们整个周末都在处理雷曼，
contracts were supposed to offset risk, not create it, right? But by now, we know that safety systems also introduce new ways for things to go wrong. The insurance contracts that were about to destroy AIG were called credit default swaps. They had become popular as a way to offset risk with the blessing of regulators. They seemed a smart idea. Just as the third support for the columns seems like a smart idea, and the metal filters at the Fermi reactor and the duplicate set of award envelopes. But they backfired. Wall Street banks were relying on these credit default swaps to keep them safe if there
现在又出了这个？我们他妈的怎么把过去的 48 小时花在错误的事情上了？”确实如此。原因与他们把奥斯卡颁给错误的电影完全一样：混乱的沟通，以及最致命的——一个创造了全新失败途径的安全系统。2008 年的银行危机震撼了全球金融系统，摧毁了数百万个工作岗位。十多年后的今天，我们依然在承受着这些后果。从某种意义上说，
was trouble. When it became clear that insurance companies such as AIG couldn't possibly pay out, for banks all scramble to sell off their risky investments at the exact same time, for the exact same reason. A few days after Willemstadt had met Geintner, officials and bankers worked through the weekend on the Lehman Brothers problem. Only on Sunday evening did one of those bankers receive a request from a treasury official to ask if she could drop everything and work on rescuing AIG instead. The surprising phone call was greeted with a response that was unsurprisingly unsuitable for family ears. Hold on, hold on. You're calling me on a Sunday night saying that we just spent the entire weekend on layman
这是一场比任何核事故都更严重的危机。它当然远远大于奥斯卡颁奖典礼上的一栋平房，然而所有这些事故的根源都是相同的问题。在《爱乐之城》的混乱之后，《名利场》报道称：奥斯卡制定了一个严厉的六步计划，以避免再次发生信封灾难。这六个步骤包括解雇两名会计师合伙人布莱恩·库利南和玛莎·鲁伊兹，以及双重信封套装。《名利场》称，取而代之的是将有三位合伙人。第三位合伙人将与制片人一起坐在节目的控制室里。
and now we have this? How the f*** did we spend the past 48 hours on the wrong thing? How indeed. For the same reason, they gave the Oscar to the wrong movie, confusing communication, and above all, a safety system that created a brand new way to fail. The banking crisis of 2008 shook the world financial system and destroyed millions of jobs. More than a decade later we're still living with the consequences. It was, in its way,
所有三位合伙人都将拥有全套信封。如果两套信封引起了问题，三套信封就会更好，对吧？我不敢确定伽利略是否会同意。你一直在收听的是《警世故事》。我在我的书《适应》（Adapt）中扩展了本集中的一些想法，你可能会喜欢它。《警世故事》由我蒂姆·哈福德撰写并主持。我们的制作人是瑞安·迪利（Ryan Dilly）和玛丽莲·罗斯（Marilyn Rust）。声音设计和混音师是帕斯卡尔·维斯（Pascal Weise），他同时也创作了美妙的音乐。
a more serious crisis than any nuclear accident. It was, in its way, a more serious crisis than any nuclear accident. It was certainly far greater than a bungalow at the Oscars, yet the same problems were at the roots of all these accidents. After the La La Land Shambles, Vanity Fair reported. The Oscars have an intense sixth-step plan to avoid another envelope disaster. The six steps include getting rid of the two accounting partners, Brian Cullen and Martha Ruiz, and the twin sets of envelopes. Instead, says Vanity Fair, there will be three partners. A third partner will sit in the show's control room with the producers.
自从这个故事制作完成以来，本集中提到过的杰出社会学家、《正常事故》一书的作者查尔斯·佩罗已经逝世。《警世故事》是普希金工业公司（Pushkin Industries）的作品，参与制作的还有才华横溢的朱莉娅·巴顿（Julia Barton）、希瑟·范恩（Heather Fane）、米埃洛·贝尔（Miello Bell）、卡莉·麦克罗里（Carly McLeory）、雅各布·韦斯伯格（Jacob Weisberg）和马尔科姆·格拉德韦尔（Malcolm Gladwell）。我不知道你怎么能听了这集超过三分钟却还没有订阅《警世故事》，但也许你当时正在开车，或者正在洗碗，双手湿漉漉的。如果是这样，你现在就可以打开你正在收听节目的播客应用，
All three partners will have a complete set of envelopes. If having two sets cause the problem, having three sets is better, right? I'm not sure Galileo would agree. You've been listening to Corsionary Tales. I expand on some of the ideas in this episode in my book Adapt, You Might Like It. Corsionary Tales is written and presented by me, Tim Halford. Our producers are Ryan Dilly and Marilyn Rust. The sound designer and mixer was Pascal Weise, who also composed the amazing music.
订阅《警世故事》。我想总共应该有八集，我希望这是一个大热节目，因为我希望有几十集更多的内容让我大饱耳福。99% Invisible 是旧金山 KALW 91.7 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row 制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的联合体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。
In the time since this story was produced, Charles Perot, the brilliant sociologist and author of Normal Accidents, who was mentioned in the episode, passed away. Cautionary Tales is a production of Pushkin Industries, including the talented Julia Barton Heather Fane, Miello Bell, Carly McLeory, Jacob Weisberg, and Malcolm Gladwell. I don't know how you could have listened to more than three minutes of this episode and not subscribed to Cautionary Tales, but maybe you were driving or you were doing the dishes in your hands were wet. If so, you can remedy that right now by opening up the podcast app you're listening
你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或者@本节目 @99PI，我们下周将推出一集由我们制作的新节目。但如果你在此期间需要过过瘾，你随时可以访问 99IPI.org。广播至永远。来自 PRX。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
to and subscribe to cautionary tales. There's supposed to be eight episodes, I think, and I'm hoping it's a monster hit because I want there to be dozens more for me to listen to. 99% of Isabel is a project of KALW 91.7 in San Francisco and produced on Radio Roe, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find more at radiotopia.fm.
去订阅《警示故事》（Cautionary Tales）。我想总共应该有八集，我希望它能大受欢迎，这样我以后就有几十集可以听了。《伊莎贝尔的99%》是旧金山KALW 91.7电台的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Roe制作。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集体。了解更多信息请访问 radiotopia.fm。
You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or we'll have a new episode produced by us next week. But if you need a fix in the meantime, you can always go to 99IPI.org. Radio til the end. From PRX. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）或节目（@99PI），我们下周将推出由我们制作的新节目。但如果你在这期间需要过过瘾，随时可以访问 99PI.org。无线电直到永远。来自PRX。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。